le cofondateur d'apple steve wozniak qui
était de passage à montréal lundi soir
il n'a pas déçu les quelques 3000
personnes qui s'étaient déplacées pour
venir longtemps de parler de ce qui les
anime visiblement encore près de 40 ans
après avoir fondé ce qui est maintenant
la plus grosse compagnie au monde en
termes de capitalisation boursière
une conférence il coïncide avec une
période où bien des observateurs se
demandent quel est l'avenir de la marque
à la pomme ont sur mathieu sélune
parlons d'abord du contexte la craie
entoure cette visite à montréal
le verbe apport il n'est pas motivé du
pam à moitié plein il déborde 716
milliards de dollars de capitalisation
boursière c'est un record ils ont fait
des profits records de l'histoire des
compagnies dans le monde 18 milliards de
profits pour le dernier trimestre de
75 millions d'iphone ont été vendus le
record de profiter des tenues jusqu'à
maintenant par des compagnies
pétrolières exxon et gazprom avec 16
milliards de dollars c'est d'ios qui
sont rendus est incroyable mais quand
même il ya des points d'interrogation
sur l'avenir de cette compagnie ont
effectivement ils sont condamnés
l'excellence à port louis ventes de ipad
vont très mal
ils ont perdu en fait il part de marché
sont passés de 33 à 28 % en un an lawrie
watch
on sait pas si ce tout le monde tu vas
être adoptée on sait que les montres
connectés en a pas beaucoup sur le
marché ce marché quasi vierge mais est
ce que les gens vont aller vers une
demande qui ne peut pas être utilisé
indépendamment de son téléphone
cellulaire d'une autre chose
le service de musique en continu on sait
qu'ils libèrent les ventes d'iphone
baisse ont baissé de 15% à peuvent se
reprendre par le service de musique en
continu
est-ce que ça va fonctionner ils ont
payé 3 milliards de dollars pour beat
c'est encore des gros points
d'interrogation
oui d'ailleurs lui même était certain
doute sur les
montre pas ça les mondes connectés en
tout cas jusqu'à maintenant ils en
essayer plusieurs édifices fera vraiment
capable de convaincre que ce sera une
bonne montrent la poche mais il leur
donne quand même là l'agencé postale a
fait la chance au coureur non c'est en
tout cas c'est un gros point ces 350
dollars quand même pour cette montre le
minimum ce sera ça restera à voir le
succès de la viola rumeurs là dont tout
le monde va mal c'est cette possibilité
qu'apple s'en aille vers les voitures à
une voiture
tesla d'ailleurs grosse rumeur en fait
c'est un blogueur un investisseur un
entrepreneur jason calacanis qui lui
affirme qu'à pau va acheter cela cette
compagnie donc d'excellentes au
tout-électrique pari tenu pari lune
masque d'ici 18 mois pour 75 milliards
de dollars
la trésorerie d'apple lui permettrait il
en soit 170 milliards de dollars de cash
alors il pourra acheter deux fois tesla
mais l'autre chose c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir capot se
dirige de plus en plus vers l'automobile
la forme que ça va prendre on ne sait
pas encore mais steve wosniak le disait
lundi soir ils peuvent pas continuer à
faire des profits records avant d'en
simplement des cellulaires ils ont un
projet secret le projet titan ou
semble-t-il il serait en train de
développer leur propre automobile avec
un designer vraiment de renom marc nous
sommes des anciens de mercedez et de
ford est ce qu'ils vont racheter tesla s
qui feront leur propre tout ils vont
s'intégrer dans des d'autres d'autres
compagnies automobiles
ça reste à voir une chose est sûre siaap
a pas s'en va vers l'automobile va être
belle avec bell avec cher et hapaska
fini facilement merci beaucoup matière
plaisir